right on the back there okay now look at
this guy now
this one you might not want to pet
because they're spiking oh my god
[Applause]
so famously and so powerfully said
george bush doesn't care about black
people it makes me wonder
what makes you think that donald trump
does or
any people at all
why don't we take a break we'll come
back and uh kanye west yeah yeah
he's out there was you nervous and your
underarms was itching and stuff
uh yeah my underarms were sweating
during all the shows uh i was so nervous
um but um i i do a thing when i'm
nervous to calm myself down me too
what do you do
does it work
are you retiring excuse me
i love him not really i do like you just
won
in six years most awkward start to an
interview i think
i just forgive me if this is rude i just
want to try one thing okay
[Music]
anton what are you doing
um our identity was really questioned
and i think it explores that
in a really smart way um
now what did you have there it looks
like you got the uh pizza what do you
mean what is
that but one side is plain on one side
it looks like prosciutto with mushrooms
yeah prosciutto and it was no it was
like a
sun-dried tomato tomato my favorite i
can eat pizza like
for lunch dinner and breakfast oh this
is my this is fantastic
are you good can you cook pizza i love
pizza really yeah i love it so diverse
and great fun
and you seem like you're enjoying that
you had a whole wedge in your mouth at
any one time
you haven't yet you haven't heard of a
knife
knife and fork no you don't need pizza
with a knife and a fork you just pick it
up and stick it in of course you have to
take it
he's english
all right but are you in a cabin
somewhere yes it's a sort of lodge and
big
sorry and then and so you go out to walk
the dog
well no i sort of
do they allow dogs at the hotel aren't
you supposed to let people talk on the
show
this is a new title oh god how many do
you have i have a
cup just a couple let's go well tell me
that's the last one
it might be no no it is you don't i mean
honestly
like how does that help how does that
help how you look to have a tattoo
how does it not i mean it doesn't not
help the way i look it just expresses
yesterday my album came out it was an
important day for me
so you know i got believe get that off
hey this is a brand new
[Applause]
i have no idea what he's doing behind me
he's perfectly
[Applause]
we've talked about kinky boots recently
yes it's a fantastic show you have to go
okay roswell
sorry about that you just last respected
the table
um it's like your desk is a puzzle it is
i'm sorry about that what is the
solution
i think we could try and pour it back in
be careful because that's a low-cut drip
oh sorry okay
um i'm only fashion blood i've got
instincts oh
okay well um tell me what you need to
know um
i'm just gonna have a drink here i i
travel a lot
and so these people are at work are they
yeah they're working they're just at
work
work more quietly they're facebooking
actually what are they doing facebooking
they're facebooking yeah yeah shopping i
bet they can't look at pornography i
think it's blocked on their website
well i don't know i don't know
thanks stop saying he i'm present
what's wrong with your manners you're
good
you forget about what's important you
allow the agenda to be decided by
superficial information
what am i saying what am i talking about
don't think about what i'm wearing these
things are redundant i'm superficial
okay don't be distracted what do you
think that gesture means the way you're
touching that bottle what does that
indicate
what is that what's the subtext of that
we gotta go to break you need to lose
that ring mika because it don't mean
nothing to you
the way that i met simon was they asked
me to be a guest judge
focus conan to be um
[Applause]
i'm sorry finally we'll be real here for
a second i'm speaking up
you didn't think i was going to look
down there
[Applause]
when you do this fox show if it is
successful
are you going to change am i going to
change yeah are you going to be the same
guy you are another humble guy
i'm going to be the same dirty son of a
[ __ ] as i am now right
thank you this is live tonight we
appreciate it well that's not that's not
swearing no no
of course not no that's just i think
that's that's part of it that's fox
we're going to see that in stan hooper
aren't we no we're not going to see you
you uh i i think i met you at snatch i
don't think you remember that
the premiere of snatch the movie years
ago which they remembered
[Applause]
he's got all the cool dudes in there
benicio's in that right
michio brad uh who else was in it oh it
was
oh i was there oh look at oh would i get
beat up quick in england
oh my god spadier lady look at this guy
that was me at the premiere is that
hysterical
i didn't know how i got into that
because i didn't know you but maybe i
was famous back then but we uh
i thought it was a great movie that was
super cool back then i knew it was at
the dga
remember that director's guild have you
done this interview before
keep going okay keep going i did think
he was there to be interviewed
he didn't seem to want to be interviewed
he didn't seem to want to talk to you
really it seemed like it was a weird
thing you would ask a question and then
like there was there was a point where i
go do you want me to talk for a while
yeah
i talked and then he sort of listened to
me but afterwards he goes great job i go
me
i thought we were going to get a fight
well i've been working on my music
music but you know when i saw you in in
walk the line i said this guy
is tremendous he's singing and it
sounded great
so is that the kind of music you're
interested in no
no i do um more hip-hop music hip-hop
music
um this is a joke
what do you what do you have the mom i'm
sorry
i'm sorry what are you saying what are
you gassing up with
just nitrous the kid in the front is
drunk on warm pepsi
[Music]
do you have any any fun stories to tell
us
[Applause]
is that that's fun just relax seriously
i'll come to your house and chew gum
i don't have to no just relax